boa noite gente muito muito muito feliz
de estar aqui e honrado por essas
para que todo mundo já está contando a
nasa já razzano sa ea primeira coisa
quando comecei a pensar o que poderia
falar aqui de tanta coisa que eu tenho
vivido é sobre exemplo a e aí eu queria
que você fizesse exercícios ao final a
gente retoma de lembrem tem que tomar
algo que vocês fazem no dia a dia uma
atitude que vocês têm o que você já
incorporaram ao dia a dia que vocês
tomaram de exemplo de alguém não precisa
necessariamente ser alguém que você
conhece pessoalmente pode ser que seja
grande pescoço especialmente mas que
seja uma atitude que você viu a pessoa
fazendo e isso te imobilizou isso é uma
forma de potencializar a ser uma pessoa
melhor
pequenas coisas pequenas coisas mesmo
aquelas que são esses detalhes
é eu sempre costumo falar que eu sou
meio de uma esponja então eu vou olhando
o que as pessoas vão fazendo eo que ela
tem de legal alguma atitude bacana que
elas fazem eu tomo isso pra minha vida e
vou levando isso é uma forma é uma forma
bastante interessante de pensar em uma
foto que é um exemplo incrível para mim
que quando a gente fala de exemplo a pra
mim vem essa imagem aqui essa meus pais
e os meus sobrinhos alguns deles e essa
geladeira chegou faz umas duas semanas
em casa eu não moro há fisicamente com
eles mais mas chegou na casa dele e ver
se aquela geladeira trocada seu negócio
e foi uma festa é meus pais a amaram
minha mãe surtou
meu pai é amor que não pode não
precisava mais abaixo rápido e as costas
é e aí ela resolveu tirar a foto e isso
é muito maravilhoso ela estava tentando
pintar o cabelo se arrumou júri ela o
menino vai falar isso fui por falar que
seu cabelo ea yahoo motor e é muito
legal aqui na foto tem meu sobrinho
tentando fugir da roubada da fóton é
obviamente em cima aquela forma de bolo
todo mundo conhece que nossos pais
colocar pra gente alcançar e essa foto é
um marco para mim porque ela diz muito
sobre a minha vida e sobre meus pais
meus pais foram dinheiros que até hoje é
um exemplo para mim
porque eles saíram a gente saiu né de
lado o maranhão de tonton a
provavelmente nem conhece uma cidade
muito pequena ea gente teve uma uma
trajetória de vida acho muito parecida
com muita gente muitos brasileiros a que
foi a de procurar oportunidades assim
como ana ficou várias pessoas vieram
aqui a gente meus pais saíram na verdade
só meu pai é tão diferente é de alguma
outra história do meu pai saiu sozinho
para rondônia que é uma loucura porque
ninguém conhecia água e quase ninguém
conhece ainda mas imagine só a dos anos
90 foi para lá para rondônia para tentar
a vida sozinho e aí deixou a gente isso
combinado taxa fique claro e aí
conseguiu depois de um ano atrás a gente
volta a levar minha mãe minhas irmãs
todo mundo lá pra cá a rondônia para
recomeçar a vida e isso é muito marcante
para mim a força que eles tiveram de
fazer isso quando chegou lá não foi
fácil foi extremamente difícil porque
eram vários problemas de emprego minha
pai minha mãe não toma nenhuma
estabilidade minha mãe de sua família
toda lá enfim e há bem pouco tempo atrás
eu descobri que minha mãe ea vapor
várias vezes fazer uns truques lá em
casa quando eu era pequeno pra que a
gente não percebeu que não tinha tanta
comida então ela faz uma divisão lá
muito louca de videobingo em vários
pedaços mas disse não perceber que de
alguma forma não era o suficiente e só
soube há bem pouco tempo quando ela por
acaso resolveu falar
o meu pai que já fez tanto trabalho de
tudo que você imaginar em até trabalhar
num mercado em plena madrugada e o mais
louco pra mim é que durante muitos anos
meus parentes sempre jogaram muito
pessoais porque ele sempre foi muito
aberto com a gente então eu sempre
confiaram muito na gente isso era
incrível então não brigará brigavam e se
eles não eram impositivos no que eles
fazem para a gente eles confiavam e de
alguma forma que a gente mudasse
completamente a forma que a gente lida
com as coisas então é eu que não
precisava fazer nada ruim eu não queria
fazer nada que não agradasse eles pela
confiança que eles me davam então isso
mudar completamente a forma de lidar e
eu sempre fala que o agente só é o que é
porque meus pais foram assim
esse é o maior exemplo é pra mim e isso
da perseverança meus pais têm de lutar
às vezes nem sabe que ele só você no
exemplo pra mim eu prometo minhas irmãs
mas eu sempre queria cresci com essa
coisa do vai dar certo sempre imaginava
quando eu tô fazendo alguma coisa ou pra
começar a faculdade vai dar certo do
jeito que dá não sei como é que vou
pagar
não sei que que jeito que eu vou dar pra
acontecer mas vai dar certo isso pra
tudo então comecei a trabalhar
comecei a fazer um estágio é faculdade
também pagava de várias formas
há por exemplo uma delas pra economizar
a grana então eu pegava um trecho de
bicicleta até um posto de gasolina que é
meu brother lá em rondônia e até 13 para
não precisar pagar pegar dois ônibus e
sempre eu lembro que ficava muito claro
na minha cabeça que aquilo ali não era
uma punição divina ou alguma coisa de
ruim que estava acontecendo comigo pra
mim está muito claro que aquilo era
passageiro que aquilo ali servir de
alguma forma para que eu me tornasse uma
pessoa melhor e é isso que me motiva a
fazer muita coisa e aí nessa questão de
exemplo eu gosto muito de um exemplo
muito a simples que eu acho que é esse
tipo de exemplo que motiva eu tenho uma
grande amiga que quando você está gear
ela me ensinou a revisar e mails antes
de mandar e sempre começava a mandar
louco milhares e milhares perderam tempo
mandato qualquer jeito vários erros não
erros de português mas erros de
digitação e aí ela começou a falar há
sempre fez isso ela soube antes de
enviar quando está no botão de ar para
reler o que se escreveu e manda e isso
faz até hoje e é um grande exemplo está
bem pequeno mas são desses exemplos acho
que a gente vai lembrando bom e aí
resolvi ir para são paulo a pra retocar
é pra tocar a vida é eu queria estudar
design que eu também acho que eu sempre
achei que você vai querer que o design é
uma ferramenta de mudança na vida das
pessoas não tem uma grana em 2001
7 pra ir pra são paulo em 2008 fui para
lá para estudar design e aí as coisas
começaram a acontecer
comecei a trabalhar comecei a estudar
fazer várias coisas lá em são paulo
iniciada a aula lá no próprio instituto
e as coisas vão ótimas e não tavam não
era um martírio para mim ela amava da
aula mas começou a surgir uma
inquietação não é então que era o que eu
posso fazer mais né e eu ficava muito
alinhado porque eu sabia tanta coisa
legal estava acontecendo tanto história
legal que as pessoas faziam e ninguém
estava sabendo e o ápice dessa
indignação foi no dia 11 de agosto em
que uma amiga publicou essa história em
11 de agosto 2012 e eu comentei embaixo
eu coloquei existem razões para
acreditar
e aí na hora de caiaque raio na cabeça e
ele fala caramba cabeça da história nas
no site está dessa história da mídia não
tem então resolvi criar um site do jeito
que eu sabia não tinha idéia de hoje
press de toda essa coisa de redes
sociais mas eu tinha uma idéia muito
clara as pessoas precisam saber as
coisas legais só nascendo mundo e eu
preciso mostrar por a mais b que tem
muita coisa legal diferente do que a
gente imagina que a gente sempre vê na
grande mídia que é tudo o que vocês é
que a gente já vê de pessoas brigando
vocês reclamando e mostrar um universo
possível não o tópico que a gente sempre
falante não nega as coisas ruins estão
acontecendo a gente só escolheu não
falar que já tem gente demais fazendo e
as razões era um blog começou bem
pequenininho 2012 começou a crescer ea
paz 17 anos esse ano em aos quatro anos
atrás e se tornou um negócio
então acho que é legal também falar que
não é nada que de repente se ter uma
idéia legal e ela de repente vira um
negócio super bacana
foi um processo muito difícil porque é
um negócio novo vai surgindo mas hoje em
dia você ter uma idéia a gente tem quase
dez pessoas trabalhando com a gente
entre sócio entre tratores entre galeras
inteligência e aí o que a gente faz
elevar as histórias que eu acho que
algum de vocês
essa é aquela só de inspiradora aquelas
obras que dão um quente no coração que
fazem chorar no banheiro do bar sozinho
a gente fica feliz é para o universo das
marcas porque elas são extremamente
carentes de contar histórias legais as
responsabilidades não estão
completamente desconectados o que é
realmente interessante de contar ea
gente resolveu levar isso então razões
em dia um negócio que tem algumas é
algumas movimentações de alguns caminhos
e tem hoje atualmente milhões de pessoas
impactadas
então a gente tem um site com 5 milhões
de acessos mensais entre facebook e
instagram gente tem quase 2 milhões de
pessoas que nos seguem
e aí eu acho que é o mais legal a gente
tem um impacto de milhões de pessoas
mas é quando eu fiquei sabendo de uma
pessoa que foi impactado por alguma
história e isso muda completamente
porque não é o número é alguém que
entendeu aquilo e de alguma forma se
potencializou pelo exemplo que estava
dando uma delas é o gustavo que virou
meu amigo ele há quatro anos atrás me
mandou um boxe e ele falou oi vicente
tudo bem eu queria só que agradecer
porque os exemplos de histórias que
conta aqui me fazem querer ir para a
quimioterapia toda semana eu tô na
quarta reincidência de câncer e não tem
mais é quase redes sociais só se vocês
porque é a forma que encontrei de me
inspirar a querer ser uma pessoa melhor
ea querer me curar
quando ele falou isso é foi um choque
não pô não saber disso a gente sabe que
a gente respira
mas saber que a gente potencializa
alguém a mudar de atitude a ele falou
que a gente tinha muita raiva da doença
tinha uma lástima por conta disso ele
começou a entender que aquilo também a
ser parte do processo dele e fará
quimioterapia feliz da vida está
arrumando e tudo mais
e ainda não está curado quatro anos
depois ele continua com toda a energia
possível
atuando e fazendo tudo ou diego que ele
van
lá no paraná ele criou uma eco barreira
que é um rio que passa no quintal da
casa dele que pega um pedaço do terreno
que as filhas deles perguntava a ikea
que está acontecendo de tanto o clássico
de tanta coisa que passa aqui que pode
ser feito o que a gente vai fazer e aí
ele falou que teve a idéia de fazer uma
barreira com barris de de que eles
gasolina normalzinho e essa barreira
extremamente simples barra literalmente
todo esse plástico que vem chegando e
não sou plástico e falou que já chegou
tv já chegou tudo que você imaginar em e
ele recolhe esse plástico e ao longo de
uns três anos que tem as ideias já
recolheu duas toneladas de resíduos
você tem idéia de que uma pessoa sozinha
fazer uma coisa tão grande de duas
toneladas e ainda pega essa esse
plástico e vende e consegue ajudar fila
e tudo mais então imagina o poder que
você tem de com uma história que você
está contando uma história que você está
fazendo você potencializa várias pessoas
muita gente vai lá para aprender como é
que faz e empresas estão querendo saber
o que é muito simples agente tipo é uma
solução extremamente fácil ou a
francisca que ela mora em aparecida de
goiânia
do lado de um lixão e ela quando
perguntei para ela sobre o exemplo a sua
recente eu não tive escolha
o meu exemplo que eu quero fazer o que
quero da eu não tinha escolha do que
transformar esse exemplo tinha que fazer
eu tenho filhas ela tem bastante é
filhos eu tinha várias pessoas estavam
perto de mim e que não tinha idéia de
como sobreviver
resolvi fazer uma coisa e ela ajudou a
ajuda à comunidade ela lidera mais de
400 famílias com reciclagem com uma
série de coisas e muda a vida de uma
centena de pessoas com essa força que
ela tem que é incrível
e aí publicamos a história dela eu acho
que é importante falarmos pública
obviamente histórias e hoje em dia ganha
uma repetição
gigantesca o que é muito maravilhoso da
gente na contra mão né das notícias de
que notícia ruim viralizar a gente vai
mostra o contrário no sabor vir a juízo
da incrível e vai parar todo o programa
de tv
e essa história aqui a gente encontra no
site dela no site razões e pouco tempo
depois ela me mandou esse áudio e assim
amigo eu te agradeço imensamente nessa
frente
não sei se você lembra vou te falar que
eu tinha 11 lançar em são paulo é eu
gostaria muito encontrar elas e
encontrei viu
encontrei as irmãs contra everton pelos
irmãos o meu pai à minha família
muito obrigada meu muito obrigada
é surreal você impactar a vida de alguém
de uma forma tão profunda e falando
impactar pelo poder do exemplo a gestão
é só eu não sou relativamente recente no
razões que foi do capoeira que um
guardador de carros lá do rio
se alguém em algum momento ouviu a
história a gente publicou o vídeo dele
ajudando uma senhora a atravessar a rua
estava uma incrível chuva e ele teve um
choque com o caixote ela foi pisando ele
pisando na água e ajudando ela a gente
publicou o vídeo e aí foi uma loucura o
vídeo por dois motivos 1 pela atitude
dele que foi por isso que a gente
publicou
e o outro foi que não estava claro pelo
trecho do vídeo ela tinha agradecido e
aí foi uma loucura
essa é a raiz craca não pode ela não
agradecer o que não quer
e aí a gente a gente calma o vídeo é um
pedaço da história então a gente não tem
como saber o que aconteceu eu não vou
procurá lá pra saber por que a pessoa
que merece que eu procure saber o que
aconteceu é a pessoa da ação que foi
ficar aqui até não saber o nome e aí
internet loucura rede vão pro xoxa
fiz um post falando gente alguém sabe
que é essa a onde aqui no rio só sei que
no rio e aí começou ainda só que eu
queria no copacabana na chama copacabana
rafael capoeira aí uma pessoa falou que
a thales que virou uma grande amiga
quando a gente mora aqui do na hora que
guarda os carros aqui na minha rua pedir
para ligar falei vou falar com ele
porque queria saber
e aí falei com ele e falei capoeira é
como está essa história na área mas
dessa senhora isso é uma gente toma
banho de boa nem sabe qual contracena e
aí falar mas ela se lembra dela
agradeceu tudo ele pô eu agora sou
caramba como o betão trocar não sei o
que falei pô é isso precisava saber
eu vou fazer uma matéria espero que seja
bacana pra você e aí disse
possam os yo que pudesse acontecer pra
mim o que se essa história viralizar eu
queria a que o meu filho tivesse uma
casa e aí contei a história
a matéria recebeu fazer uma vaquinha e
aí essa loucura meu tempo está acabando
e vou falar é a vaquinha que não tinha
idéia de como funcionava a gente em três
dias a gente passou de 20 mil que era a
meta inicial para 40 mil no final do dia
e pará em três dias 170 mil
e aí sem noção do que é transformar a
vida de um cara a gente já já tem a casa
dele é comprada agora está indo a
questão de reforma e tal e aí a gente é
tão louco que a gente resolveu agora
fazer uma própria plataforma pra
financiar coletivamente é uma plataforma
de vaquinhas para financiar outras
histórias então agora além de contar
essa história que a gente tem feito tão
bem
agora a gente está fazendo uma história
é isso muito obrigado
brigar
[Aplausos]